[Music]
this morning we continue our special and
i mean that special series kindness 101
with steve hartman who's sharing stories
that are built around themes of kindness
and character and the people who have
mastered those qualities in today's
lesson it's about compassion steve and
his kids show us how one boy found his
own home which inspired him to help
others find theirs
good morning i'm here with my daughter
meryl hi and she's going to help me
teach a lesson about compassion
what is compassion for that we go to my
brother emma at the dictionary desk
emmett good morning everyone compassion
is to feel sympathy for someone who is
sad or disappointed yeah it's kind of
that feeling you get inside that makes
you want to help someone in need or some
animal in need
we got a dog recently
i did not want to get a dog but you know
why i went along with it
because mommy really wanted one she
wears the pants
yes
but also because pets teach compassion
and if you treat a pet with compassion
there's a good chance you're going to
grow up to treat people that same way
too
i've got a story this morning i want to
share with you that illustrates this
point perfectly it's a classic from the
archives featuring the boy who has
become my role model for compassion
eight-year-old robbie gay loves an
underdog
bring him to the flagler county humane
society in palm coast florida as we did
and ask him to find a favorite
he will seek out the oldest mangiest
least adoptable mutt of the lot there's
something about old dogs but i just like
do you see yourself in these dogs
yes sir
he knows what it feels like not to be
loved and cared for he's the most
hopeful optimistic and genuinely caring
kid who has absolutely no reason to be
that way
robbie's adoptive mom maria says before
he entered the foster system robbie was
a holy terror so badly abused he was
twice hospitalized with brain injuries
then two years ago maria and her husband
charles adopted him
it was just a good day
what did that day mean to you
everything
he has come a long way except in this
one respect
maria says he could not cry
despite the horrors of his past or maybe
because of them
the kid was a stone
then one day one of his old dogs buffy
had to be put down
he insisted on holding her till the very
end
perhaps because he knew it was the
release
he needed
after robbie finally let go he told his
mom i know how it feels not to be loved
or cared for and i don't want any animal
of mine to feel that way
nor does he want any foster kid to feel
that way
because people don't want to order
people and older dogs
they only want babies and puppies
he is so
aware that it could have gone totally
differently for him and in these older
dogs robbie's found a place to
practice compassion
someday robbie wants to adopt older
foster children himself go up and knock
on the door but until then to show his
commitment and do what he can he has
vowed to adopt as many old dogs as his
parents will allow he love her today
it's a lame snaggletooth shih tzu named
molly molly's owner had to go into
assisted living but molly got a new home
thanks to the sweet little boy who sees
his reflection
in the eyes of the suffering
robbie and his mom maria join us now
hello
hi
robbie i know you just lost molly not
long ago i'm sorry about that okay but
your mom also surprised you with a new
old dog and we have some video of that
easy
you seem like you were pretty surprised
when you got off the bus
yes he had no idea he can hear and he
can see
is this rare that you have a dog that
can see and hear totally scary and
what's that dog's name
chewie lewis and the news so we can call
him louie i only have one dog how many
dogs are you allowed to have
some of these older dogs we might only
have them for a month so if you only
have them for a little while
what makes you want to keep doing it
because all dogs deserve to be loved
i don't think of when they when they're
going i think of how they feel right now
thank you so much for what you've done
and thank you very much for joining us
it was really nice to meet you kiddos
robbie has made a place in his heart to
love the lonely
and if you do the same
compassion will always follow
we'll see you next time until then stay
kind
steve does it again it's hard to pick a
favorite with steve but that's really up
in my top man just pulls at the heart
strings how about the little boy when he
said i know how it feels not to feel
loved and cared for nobody should feel
that now he wants to give that back he
couldn't cry can you imagine that no a
boy so badly abused that he couldn't cry
he finally did when he lost his dog